as the eclipse moves East Nashville will
be the largest city to experience
so-called totality thousands of visitors
are pouring in for a Nashville style
celebration David Begg knows at the
Grand Ole Opry will they'll host a
viewing party David good morning mr.
Mason good morning something tells me a
music man like yourself would have loved
to have this assignment but I was all
too happy to say yes it's been 500 years
since music city's had a total eclipse
and the city estimates about 90,000
people stayed here overnight to get
ready to be here this morning
now look Nashville does business
conventions and celebration parties well
but the question is exactly how many
people have come here Nashville is about
a one-day drive for a 165 million people
that many people could get to Nashville
in about a day so the question is how
many people drove here and how many
folks might be stopping on the side of
the road or in a random parking lot just
to gaze up at the sky we've got a drone
in the air took some footage at the
Grand Ole Opry you're gonna have upwards
of 900 maybe a thousand people but the
property includes the Gaylord Opryland
Hotel the Opry Mills Mall
so when you factor it all the folks who
may be there you could have thousands of
people just on this piece of property
looking up when the Eclipse happen is I
look up right now the cloud coverage
isn't too bad
the city has handed out about 4,000
glasses and Anthony the glasses are key
when you put them on by the way you'll
notice you don't see a darn thing until
you actually look up at the Sun and then
it all becomes clear and a little tidbit
for you if you want to use your phone to
take a picture the experts tell us put
your phone inside the glass that's the
best way to take it because it can
actually damage your cell phone lens mr.
Mason mr. Begg know many thanks big show
coming up soon for now but for now let's
go back to studio 57 in New York